vamos ver o que é que eu tenho dentro de
grendon nossa micro câmera e en 321 vai
hoje começar o vídeo como certo no álbum
uhuuu
não estava esperando esse lado pessoal
do que falou da acrissul eu às vezes
acho que evitar que muito rápido as
pessoas não conseguem resultar pelo
bacharel em direito e em um estádio de
que sua um tema do vídeo muito louco
vejam só que eu comprei um produto que
vai diretamente da china
[Música]
eu comprei endoscópio wifi e pra quem
não sabe o que é um endoscópio
endoscópio é tipo uma mini câmera ó com
dois metros ea câmara está bem aqui na
ponta
olha isso é bem pequena basicamente por
ele é usado pelos títulos pelos
cirurgiões agora israel pode ter usado
pra ver todo tipo de buracos não é que
posso estou a pensar o tribunal acredita
que da primeira regata o ouvido o nariz
ea boca
costumo isso vai tudo até lá mas eu vou
observar o meu corpo com esta quebra
2005 em erechim para desenvolver o meu
ouvido também estava em seus conselhos
não é coisa que eu não sei se você é
capaz de fazer eu vou enfiar estudo de
dois metros dentro da minha garganta e
vamos ver até onde é que eu consegui
enfiar mas com ordem só lá que eu vou
gravar eu vou ligar a nossa quebra isso
aqui é só ligar o iphone por wifi faça
uma coisa também pessoal deixei muito
vai ter que nos filho porque se vocês
acharem muito mais que eu sei que vocês
vão gostar do conteúdo e vou trazer mais
vídeos com nosso endoscópio observar
mais coisas já agora como e também o que
é que vocês querem que eu vejo tipo se
disse neste mês que eu não consigo ver
como é normal hoje vou ver o meu corpo e
nos próximos vídeos pois eu vou ler os
vossos comentários que vulneram escolher
o que comer
eu não venho melhorando durante duas
semanas eu não sou meio dentro já não
sei quando depois convenção para você
seguir é quanto tempo o novo modelo
e também já não toma banho a 7 mesmo
portanto toda a parte do meu corpo está
suja então vamos encontrar muita coisa
mas maior só sabem deixei muito aqui nos
filhos para discutirem deste conteúdo e
como tem também mais coisas para
observar porque futuramente vou fazer
mais vídeos como nas endoscópio então
comenta o assunto coisas que eu não
consigo te proceder com uma câmera
normal se diz completamente inacessíveis
só com esta quebra é claro e selar uma
canalização um esgoto mas bonita dá pra
ver muita coisa portanto comentem mas
foi lá só se chega de enrolar e como é
que eu digo não se descobre muito fácil
o foco agora é só chegar aqui não vai
faz só espero que funcione ainda não
está aí então tinha que ter um time em
boa sintoma do juiz já tem um filho e
agora vamos ligar aqui em nossa época de
visualização olha aí vamos ver em tempo
real será que o paraná só a primeira
coisa que observasse no meu ouvido e eu
acho que eu não sei mas eu devo ter
muita procura e no amigo haja tube e
éton vip lei eu contei nove câmeras
banda estão problema de focagem pouco
meu ouvido é muito pequeno então isto
nem tem espaço pra ficar mas vamos
tentar ver o meu outro houve 31 vai
ficar pior
a gente podia de coisa amarela em
anúncio à imprensa e meu deus aonde
souza o que é amar eu tenho alguma coisa
preta dentro do novo só como vocês
puderam ver 9 não dá pra ver muita coisa
então já colocar neles vamos ter o nosso
nariz button tem muito pelos a otto ver
mesmo assim isso eu vou jogar mas vou
tentar ficar o máximo possível
outras meninas olhei especial estão no
meio do meu nariz
como assim é muito lucro subir mais que
não tenha mais a tocar em qualquer coisa
que nunca disse não ter muita porcaria
estou sentido aí que o carro vai entrar
é muito difícil focar e procurar que é
muito pequeno eu vou tentar enfiar mais
tudo aparenta agora que esta deve ser
igual à outra
oi não olha para o céu em busca do filme
garganta não opera vou ter que lavar
esse infeliz pioneirismo tem que limpar
muito bem e agora está com aquelas
figurinhas com álcool já tem festa já
tão limpa tudo para o pessoal endoscópio
negado vamos ver o que é que eu tenho de
querer ver com nossa micro câmera e en
321 vai cova ó ó a ok vou tentar enfiar
agora umas impossível só vi achei muito
legal aqui neste dia isso vai ser muito
arriscado e comecei muito em baixo vai
dar vai dar vai dar que vai dar que vai
dar que expandem comentem muitos
comentários que pressentir a nossa força
nossa energia eu vou tentar enfiar o
estudo dentro da igreja para 32 cuba não
dá pra fazer isso vão fazer isso em casa
que lembrando que pode ser perigoso não
é tudo o que os médicos que fazem isso
os copinhos que não é provável a nossa
grega portanto eu vou fazer isso só
porque eu sou doido mas não façam
estoques só servem só admito o pessoal
eu acho que vou ficar porque o espírito
eu também não consigo observar se muito
mais do meu corpo mas é isso aí foi o
vídeo observando meu corpo com o
endoscópio espero que vocês tenham
gostado e só fiquei meta aproximar